Herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße wieder alle hier bei der mittlerweile 15. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie, wo wir alles versuchen, zu thematisieren, was relevant sein kann für das Verständnis des Wissenschaftsprozesses, der Bildung und vieler anderer Facetten, die wir hier schon beleuchtet haben. Und heute wollen wir uns mal wieder mit Bildung ganz konkret auseinandersetzen. Wollen darüber sprechen, wie Hochschulen sich organisieren oder vielleicht auch organisieren sollten und auch, welche Herausforderungen die Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft hier stellt. Und ich freue mich auf Muriel Helbig. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag hallo.
Ja Sie sind die, wie sagt man?
Präsidentin.
Die Präsidentin, Sie sind die Präsidentin und zwar der Fachhochschule in Lübeck. Und das auch noch gar nicht so lange?
Nein seit August letzten Jahres. Also August 2014 habe ich das Amt angetreten, nachdem ich im Januar gewählt worden bin.
Genau und wir wollen mal ein bisschen reinhören, wie es so ist, eine Hochschule zu organisieren. Und vielleicht auch in dem Zuge auch gleich ein bisschen zu reformieren. Aber bevor wir das tun würde ich ganz gern noch ein bisschen auf Sie selber zu sprechen kommen. Was war denn so Ihr Weg in die Wissenschaftswelt, wie fing denn das eigentlich an?
Mit dem eigenen Studium würde ich sagen. Also ich habe in Potsdam Psychologie studiert und dort auch abgeschlossen, nachdem ich eigentlich nur mein Vordiplom dort machen wollte und dann zurück in die USA gehen. Aber dann hat es mir so gut gefallen in Deutschland und in Potsdam und in dem Studium, dass ich geblieben bin bis zum Abschluss und von dort aus eine Promotion angeschlossen habe in Jena. Das war aus einem wirklich fachlichen Interesse. Ich hatte eine Diplomarbeit geschrieben zu Diskriminierungserfahrung ausländischer Wissenschaftler und Studierenden in Berlin/Brandenburg und wollte unbedingt weiter in dem Thema arbeiten. Bin also nach Jena gegangen.
In welchem Studiengang war das dann?
Psychologie. Ich habe Psychologie studiert und bin dann nach Jena gegangen, um dort in dem Bereich zu promovieren. Da gab es eine DFG-gefördertes internationales Graduenten Kolleg und das hatte wirklich ganz fantastische Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler und Kooperationen mit England und Belgien und ich habe meine Promotion dann in Kooperation mit einer Universität in Israel geschrieben und das war unglaublich spannend, aber im Anschluss wusste ich, dass ich in der Wissenschaft selber nicht bleiben möchte. Und hatte dann das Angebot, an der Universität zu bleiben, aber in den Wissenschaftsmanagementbereich einzusteigen. Und das erste Thema, mit dem ich beschäftigt war noch an der Universität Jena, war, Doktorandenausbildung, Graduiertenförderung, also Doktoranden Postdocs, wissenschaftlicher Nachwuchs eben. Da habe ich ein paar Jahre gearbeitet und das war mein Einstieg ins Wissenschaftsmanagement.
Das war eine Berufsgruppe, die mir vorher ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht aufgefallen ist. Also während meines Studiums und während ich promoviert habe, habe ich kaum gemerkt, dass um mich rum Manager sitzen, die das ganze auch für mich mit organisieren. Auch wenn ich tagtäglich mit denen zu tun hatte. Ich habe das nicht so eingeordnet, dass das ein Berufsfeld ist.
Ja ich würde auch sagen, das ist unterrepräsentiert. Das macht man sich glaube ich nicht so klar. Wo wirken die denn überall?
Das ist die Schnittstelle zwischen den Wissenschaftlern und der Verwaltung zum einen, und zum anderen aber auch ganz stark zu den Projektträgern. Also wir haben ja in der Hochschullandschaft mehr und mehr Drittmittelprojekte im Vergleich zur Grundfinanzierung der Hochschulen steigt ja der Anteil der Drittmittelprojekte. Auch zum Beispiel dadurch, dass der Bund nicht direkt fördern darf und da braucht man Leute, die diese Projekte akquirieren, managen, verwalten, durchführen und damit sind die Wissenschaftler rein kapazitär einfach überfordert inzwischen. Und da hat sich eine Berufsgruppe herausgebildet, die an allen möglichen Stellen sitzt und Projekte koordiniert oder auch generell. Der Verwaltungsbereich ist auch nicht mehr ein reiner Verwaltungsbereich. Administration, die werben ja zum Teil auch eigene Drittmittel ein und entwickeln sich weiter. Also ist ein ganz dynamisches Feld, inzwischen kann man das auch studieren.
Seit wann bezeichnet man das überhaupt so? Also wann hat sich dieser Begriff dann herausgebildet? Klingt jetzt so ein bisschen, als ob das erst ein Phänomen der letzten 20 Jahre ist.
Ja, ich glaube vorher gab es diesen Begriff noch nicht. Ich weiß, dass wir immer sehr hart darum gerungen haben, nicht als Verwaltung bezeichnet zu werden. Nicht weil Verwaltung schlecht ist, sondern weil es einfach diesen dynamischen und strategischen Aspekt nicht so gut widerspiegelt, der auch noch mit dabei ist. Also das ist eine gestalterische Tätigkeit mit dabei. Das ist in der Verwaltung oftmals auch so, aber es ist halt auch tatsächlich sehr förderlich, wenn man diesen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund selber hat, um besser zu verstehen, was passiert.
War das denn in der Universität Jena war das ja?
Ja.
War denn dann der Wissenschaftsmanagementbereich hatte der auch sagen wir mal den Raum, so wirken zu können? Also sich auch so dynamisch um alles kümmern zu können? War das schon wirklich ein Teil des Systems oder war das auch noch etwas, was sich erst mal freiräumt und versucht, Zugriff zu erhalten auf die Prozesse?
Nein, also Sie können diesen Bereich ja gar nicht aufbauen, wenn Sie nicht die Wissenschaftler haben, die dahinter stehen und das mit akquirieren. Also ich hatte das große Glück, dass da eine sehr sehr aktive Professorin tätig war, Amelie Mummendey, die sich gegen Ende ihrer Karriere  nochmal ganz verstärkt der strukturellen Verbesserung der Möglichkeiten für die Nachwuchswissenschaftler verschrieben hat. Und die hat sich Mitstreiter gesucht, die das gemeinsam mit ihr aufbauen und durchführen und hat mich da in dem Bereich auch sehr gefördert. Also es ist nicht so, dass man sich hinstellt und sagt, so ich möchte Sie jetzt gerne koordinieren, bitte nehmen Sie mich, sondern es ist so, dass erkannt wird, dass eine Koordinierung hilfreich sein könnte und dass man versucht die mit zu akquirieren, wenn man ein Projekt startet.
Und von wem wird dann das wissenschafts- also hat das Wissenschaftsmanagement automatisch quasi einen Zugriff auf diesen Prozess oder ist das mehr so eine Beratungsleistung und die Professoren/Wissenschaftler kommen auf einen zu und sagen, hier höre mal, wir wollen da einen Drittmittelfond irgendwie anwerben, könnt ihr uns dabei unterstützen? Oder ist das wirklich schon Teil des Prozesses, dass das Wissenschaftsmanagement an der Stelle auch automatisch immer am Start ist, wenn solche Verhandlungen laufen?
Der Bereich Wissenschaftsmanagement ist so vielfältig und so breit, dass ich sagen würde, mal so mal so. Es gibt zum Beispiel, nachdem ich in Jena tätig war, war ich an der Bauhaus-Universität Weimar und war dort Dezernentin. Das ist auch Administration und kann Verwaltung sein, man kann das aber auch weiter gestalten und da hatte ich die Freiräume durch die dortige Hochschulleitung, dass wir dort selber Projekte akquirieren und uns selber eine Richtung geben, selber die Strategie entwickeln, Vorschläge machen können und ziemlich viel Freiraum hatten. Das kann woanders an einer anderen Hochschule oder in einem anderen Projekt ganz anders sein. Und in Jena war das genauso, da hatten wir ein sehr offenes Klima, da haben wir sehr viel mitdiskutiert und mitgestaltet. Das kann aber auch sein, dass in anderen Bereichen man doch mehr als Koordinierungsstelle gesehen wird und solche Tätigkeiten durchführt. Also es ist ein ganz breites Feld und ich denke das hängt sehr davon ab, wo man tätig ist und mit wem.
Und mittlerweile lässt sich das auch studieren?
Richtig. Also ich habe damals noch einen dreiwöchigen Kurs belegt. Also die Deutsche Forschungsgesellschaft, die DFG, hat das damals mit der Verwaltungshochschule ins Leben gerufen und dort haben sie so Lehrgänge für junge Wissenschaftsmanagerinnen und Wissenschaftsmanager. So nannten die das. Das war so eine Möglichkeit. Es gibt noch andere in Deutschland. Das sind verschiedene Hochschulen, die sich damit profiliert haben, auch in Österreich gibt es welche. Also es ist jetzt schon deutlicher im Kommen. Und man konnte es damals glaube ich auch schon weiterbildend studieren. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau. Aber ich habe tatsächlich diesen Dreiwochenkurs gemacht und das war meine Grundlage. Der Rest war der Sprung ins kalte Wasser.
Ja so haben wahrscheinlich alle Berufe irgendwann mal angefangen oder alle Studiengänge. Nach dem Motto, das könnte man ja mal gebrauchen, ich mach da mal einen Kurs. Aber jetzt hat das mittlerweile schon Anerkennung? Also Wissenschaftsmanagement breitet sich über alle Universitäten und Hochschulen aus?
Ja. Ich denke ja. Ich habe auch das Glück gehabt, dass ich immer in einem Umfeld tätig war, die das anerkannt haben oder die das zu nutzen wussten. Sagen wir mal so. Es gibt auch immer wieder generell diesen Spagat zwischen den tatsächlichen Lehrkräften, sagen wir mal so, den Dozenten, den Professorinnen/Professoren und dem, was sie eben doch als die Verwaltung wahrnehmen und manchmal sagen, mein Gott jetzt nimmt diese andere Gruppe massiv überhand. Eigentlich sollen wir doch an Hochschulen forschen und lehren und jetzt haben wir da plötzlich noch diesen ganzen anderen Apparat aufgebaut an Personal, der uns ja Ressourcen wegnimmt von Lehre und Forschung. Davon gibt es auch einige, die das vielleicht so bewerten, aber ich denke, dass prinzipiell der Nutzen ganz gut erkannt ist.
Wobei ich dazu sagen muss, dass ich das verstehen kann, dass Sorge besteht, dass quasi neben Forschung und Lehre noch unglaublich viel anderes passiert, wo man sich immer wieder fragen muss, was ist das eigentlich der Nutzen und der Mehrwert? Also es gibt diesen schönen Begriff "Third Mission", wo man alles drunter fasst, was außerhalb von Forschung und Lehre an Hochschulen noch so gemacht wird. Und das ist, was weiß ich, Alumnibereich, Internationalisierung, die Digitalisierung, alle diese Sachen, die noch obendrauf kommen. Jetzt haben wir plötzlich das Thema Nachhaltigkeit, das Thema Gleichstellung gehört dazu, Diversity gehört dazu, Gründungen gehören dazu. Das sind lauter so Themen, die noch mehr und mehr dazu gehören und natürlich auch Personen brauchen, die es machen. Und dadurch wird dieser Bereich immer größer, wenn man sich das im Verhältnis zu Forschung und Lehre anguckt. Ist natürlich miteinander verwoben, das kann man nicht so einfach trennen, aber ich kann verstehen, dass dann manchmal der eine oder andere die Augen aufschlägt auf seiner Professur und sich denkt, huch wo sind die ganzen Menschen hergekommen, was machen die alles?
Bevor wir vielleicht mal auch konkret auf die FH Lübeck kommen, wollte ich nochmal kurz nachhaken, Sie erwähnten die Promotionsarbeit, Diskriminierungserfahrung von Wissenschaftlern habe ich mir das gerade richtig gemerkt?
Genau, das war die Diplomarbeit von ausländischen Studierenden und Wissenschaftlern in Berlin/Brandenburg genau. Dann bin ich zur Promotion nach Jena gegangen und da habe ich mich ethnischer Identität jugendlicher Aussiedler beschäftigt. Also das blieb in dem Rahmen von Vorurteilen, Diskriminierung sozialer Gruppen.
Würde mich mal ein bisschen interessieren, was Sie da für Erfahrungen eingesammelt haben?
Bei der Diplomarbeit?
Ja, weil das ist ja sozusagen auch nochmal explizit dieser Blick Leute von außen studieren im deutschen System. Das schafft ja dann auch nochmal so eine ganz andere Blickweise auch auf den eigenen Apparat oder?
Also ich muss sagen, damals habe ich das noch sehr, also da habe ich zwei Sachen zusammen gepackt, nämlich dass was ich in der Zeitung gelesen habe und quasi theoretisches Wissen oder Konstrukt und das habe ich versucht, in dieser Diplomarbeit beides zusammen unterzubringen. Also der Aufhänger war, dass ich in einer Zeitung gelesen hatte, dass ein Professor seinen Ruf in die Region abgelehnt hatte, aus Sorge vor fremdenfeindlichen Übergriffen. Und das hat mich schwer bewegt, weil ich gedacht habe, das darf eigentlich wirklich überhaupt nicht sein. Und deswegen wollte ich wissen, wie berechtigt dessen Sorge war. Das war quasi meine Idee. Und dann haben wir es zusammengebracht mit einem ziemlich alten Konstrukt zum Thema Diskriminierung aus den 50er Jahren, wo gesagt wurde, es gibt fünf verschiedene Stufen von Diskriminierung.
Also von ganz einfacher verbaler Diskriminierung bis hin zu Genozid sozusagen. Und ich habe versucht, dieses Konstrukt tatsächlich messbar zu machen in einem Fragebogen und auch herauszufinden, welche Form von Diskriminierung denn tatsächlich erlebt wird und auch wie diese bewertet wird. Also es kann ja auch sein, dass manche sagen, ja da werde ich ab und zu mal auf der Straße so und so betitelt, aber das stört mich überhaupt nicht, das passiert mir zu Hause auch oder wie auch immer. Und das war so ein bisschen der Aufhänger. Ich habe also nicht mit diesen Personen gesprochen, sondern das war eine klassische Fragebogenanalyse. Und herausgekommen ist, dass man diese Unterscheidung in verschieden schwere Stufen der Diskriminierung vornehmen kann. Das hat funktioniert. Was nicht funktioniert hat, ist die Bewertung des selben. Also das war überhaupt keine Unterscheidung je nach Stufe und war eigentlich immer relativ gleich, ist unangenehm, sagen wir mal so.
Was ich spannend fand war, dass herauskam, dass mehr Diskriminierung erlebt wird, je besser man deutsch spricht beispielsweise. Was ja eigentlich schon darauf hinweist, dass man gut integriert ist oder dass man sich gut auskennt, aber es ist vollkommen logisch, je besser ich deutsch spreche, desto mehr verstehe ich auch, was mir gesagt wird. Und desto mehr kann ich das einordnen und auch wahrnehmen. Genau, aber das ist schon wirklich lange her, dass ich diese Arbeit geschrieben habe. Aber das hat mir so viel Spaß gemacht, dass ich da eine Promotion anschließen wollte. Und da hatte meine Professorin in Potsdam, Barbara Krahé, auch wirklich ganz großen Anteil.
Aber jetzt war der Mittelpunkt das Wissenschaftsmanagement.
Und wie kam es denn dann dazu, dass Sie zur FH Lübeck gekommen sind und dann auch noch gleich in diese leitende Position?
Richtig. Genau.
Ich habe es einfach versucht. Das ist so die Kernaussage eigentlich. Also ich habe den Weg gemacht, dass ich ein paar Jahre in Jena in der Nachwuchsförderung tätig war, dann war ich einige Jahre in einer Führungsposition im Bereich Internationalisierung tätig an der Bauhaus-Universität Weimar und dann habe ich diese Stellenausschreibung gesehen aus Lübeck. Also ich hatte einen ganz fantastischen Job und sehr vielfältigen Job und habe mich aber gefragt, wo es noch hingehen kann und das ist etwas, was ich im deutschen Hochschulsystem, besonders an kleineren Hochschulen, wirklich schwierig finde, ist, sie haben wenig Aufstiegschancen. Es gibt wenig Möglichkeiten, dass Sie sich innerhalb der eigenen Hochschule weiterentwickeln, weil es doch relativ eng gefasst ist, was es für Stellen überhaupt gibt. Also nicht, dass einem das nicht gegönnt werden würde, sondern es gibt da einfach relativ wenig. Und ich habe mich gefragt …
Bezieht sich das jetzt wirklich nur auf Hochschulen oder jetzt allgemein auch Universitäten, wie benutzen wir den Begriff jetzt?
Ach so ich benutze den Begriff Hochschulen als quasi den Sammelbegriff Universitäten und Fachhochschulen und wenn ich Universität sage, meine ich Universitäten und wenn ich Fachhochschule sage, meine ich Fachhochschule und wenn ich Hochschule sage, dann meine ich sozusagen alles.
Okay also alle.
Alle genau. Also an allen, besonders an den kleineren. An größeren hat man natürlich mehr Spielraum, aber an kleineren ist es einigermaßen schwierig, so dass ich auf den Stellen, wo ich war, nicht wusste, wie ich mich weiterentwickeln kann und dann habe ich angefangen, zu überlegen, was gefällt mir denn und was mache ich gerne und wo habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich das auch kann. Und ich war in meiner letzten Position quasi wenn man das übersetzen würde Abteilungsleiterin und Referentin des Rektors für Internationalisierung. Das heißt ich war auch in relativ vielen Runden der Hochschulleitung dabei und habe mir dann gedacht, dass ich kein Interesse hätte, das was ich jetzt mache zum Beispiel an einer anderen oder größeren Hochschule zu machen, sondern dass ich wirklich gerne in die Leitung einsteigen würde. Da gibt es dann klassischerweise zwei Posten, Rektor oder Präsident eben. Oder Kanzler, Kanzler ist Verwaltungschef und da habe ich mir dann ziemlich frech überlegt, dass Rektor oder Präsident das wäre, was mich wirklich interessieren würde.
Was aber einem zwar rechtlich offen steht, also seit einigen Jahren darf man das werden, ohne dass man Professorin oder Professor ist, aber es ist eben unüblich.
Seit einigen Jahren ist das möglich?
Ja ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht genau sagen, wie lange, aber ich weiß, dass das jetzt eine Öffnung gibt, dass man sagt, auch Personen, die sich durch ihr Berufsleben für so eine Position qualifizieren.
Okay, aber es war tatsächlich mal eine rein man muss Professor, Professorin gewesen sein, um so eine Stelle überhaupt erst denken zu können?
Ich will jetzt keine Gerüchte in die Welt setzen, aber meiner Ansicht nach war das so.
Okay.
Und dann gab es eine Öffnung, und diese Öffnungen machen aber nicht alle Hochschulen so gerne mit. Und üblicherweise sieht man die Stellenausschreibung so, dass dann dort steht, eine Professorin oder ein Professor und dann wird auf den Paragraphen des Gesetzes verwiesen, in dem man nachlesen kann, wer sich noch bewerben dürfte. Das finde ich ziemlich abschreckend, weil es ziemlich klar macht, gesetzlich sind wir dazu verpflichtet, aber tun Sie es bitte nicht. So habe ich das immer gelesen. Und Lübeck ist den komplett anderen Weg gegangen und ich habe das seitdem nie wieder so gesehen. Die haben nämlich hingeschrieben, wir suchen einen Wissenschaftsmanager oder eine Wissenschaftsmanagerin.
Für die Position?
Für die Position. Also sie haben nicht ausschließlich, sondern sie haben gesagt, wir suchen Professor, Professorin, Wissenschaftsmanager usw. Also die hatten auf jeden Fall diese Berufsbezeichnung mit …
Gleichwertig mit allen anderen genannt.
Richtig. Und das war so außergewöhnlich, da bin ich also wirklich drüber gestolpert. Und dann habe ich gelesen, was die wollten und die wollten also haben gesagt, ihr Profil Internationalisierung. Das war gerade in einer ganz heißen Phase mit Fachhochschulen und Promotionsrecht, also das ist ja auch ein Hintergrund, den ich habe. Und ich habe das gelesen und ich habe gedacht, oh, die könnten das tatsächlich ernst meinen. Ich war mir noch nicht sicher, ob die das tatsächlich ernst meinen, aber es stand so da und sie haben es auch geschafft, sich als wirklich interessante Fachhochschule zu präsentieren. Die haben das ganz kurz und knackig, eine der drittmittelstärksten Fachhochschulen Deutschlands und das fand ich so spannend, dass ich da angefangen habe, mich einzulesen. Mir war die Fachhochschule Lübeck vorher kein Begriff und vor allem hatte ich auch noch nie vorher an einer Fachhochschule gearbeitet. U nd dann habe ich gedacht, extrem spannend, ich probiere es einfach mal.
Was ist denn die Spezialisierung dieser Fachhochschule?
Die Fachhochschule Lübeck hat vier Fachbereiche, die auch so die Ausrichtungen widerspiegeln, nämlich es ist eine technisch-naturwissenschaftlich orientierte Fachhochschule mit Ingenieurwissenschaften noch dabei und Wirtschaft. Und die vier Fachbereiche decken auch genau dieses Spektrum ab, also ein ganz anderer Bereich als aus dem ich komme mit der Psychologie. Und die Schwerpunkte, die sie sich dort gesetzt haben über alle Fachbereiche hinaus sind drei. Ist Internationalisierung beziehungsweise internationales Studium ist eben E-Learning und als drittes der Technologie- und Wissenstransfer. Das sind so drei Schwerpunkte, die sie dort wirklich sehr sehr erfolgreich über die Fachbereiche hinweg praktizieren.
Internationalisierung, E-Learning und Wissenstransfer?
Ja.
Also es hat sich offensichtlich auch niemand daran gestört, dass Sie jetzt noch nicht mal den richtigen Fachbereich sozusagen hatten?
Nein.
Entscheidend war letzten Endes, ich vermute mal, das dürfte jetzt Teil der Bewerbung gewesen sein, der Hinweis, dass gerade so Themen wie Internationalisierung etc. schon vorher zum Geschäft gehörten in Jena?
Ja richtig in Weimar und in Jena auch ein Stück weit. Und was sie dort, also die haben dort wirklich ein sehr, die  haben sich sehr große Gedanken gemacht, was sie für eine Person haben wollten. Also mein Vorgänger wollte nicht mehr antreten, er ist jetzt Professor an der Fachhochschule und da haben die sich sehr genau überlegt, was für eine Person sie dort haben wollen und wo es hingehen soll. Und haben einen sehr gründlichen Auswahlprozess vorbereitet und auch durchgeführt und haben sich Kriterien überlegt, wonach sie diese Person auswählen wollen und ein Punkt dabei war, dass man ein Exposé zu den Zielen und Ideen für die Fachhochschulen einschicken sollte. Also die wollten schon sehr genau wissen, mit was für Themen man sich bewirbt. Und das war natürlich nicht ganz einfach, weil ich ja extern war, das heißt ich musste mich ziemlich einlesen und halt versuchen, herauszufinden, was herauszufinden ist und dann passten aber die Schwerpunkte eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ich habe mich halt mit Themen beworben, die die sinnvoll fanden. Sie haben vorhin gesagt, ich glaube Sie haben mal so was wie Revolution in den Mund genommen, das ist nämlich genau das, was ich dort eigentlich gar nicht machen möchte. Ich finde das ist eine verdammt starke Fachhochschule mit unglaublichen Stärken und diese gilt es einfach weiter zu stärken, weiter herauszuarbeiten und vor allem sichtbarer zu machen.
Also Internationalisierung, E-Learning, Wissenstransfer das war jetzt nicht nur Teil dieser Ausschreibung, sondern es ist generell sozusagen drei Schwerpunkte, die die Schule schon seit längerem hat?
Schon seit langem hat und sehr erfolgreich praktiziert, genau.
Und was muss man da jetzt konkret drunter verstehen unter diesen drei Begriffen? Also Internationalisierung ist ja ein sehr allgemeiner Begriff, was ist damit gemeint?
Also hier ist es sehr spezifisch zugeschnitten auf internationale Studiengänge, muss man sagen. Und da hat die Fachhochschule Lübeck zwei strategische Partner, die man hervorheben kann, nämlich einmal eine Universität in den USA und zum anderen Partner in China, mit denen sie gemeinsame Studiengänge durchführen. Und das sind zum Teil Doppelabschlussprogramme, also wo man einen Abschluss sowohl an der einen als auch an der anderen Hochschule erwirbt, zum Teil sind es aber auch Studienprogramme mit fest integrierten Auslandsaufenthalten und gegenseitigen Besuchen. Zum Beispiel mit der Milwaukee School of Engineering. Das finde ich ganz bezeichnet. Aus den USA gibt es einen Bachelorstudiengang, wo die deutschen Studierenden ein in die USA gehen und dort auch ihre Bachelorarbeit in einem amerikanischen Unternehmen schreiben.
Also das finde ich schon sehr herausragend, aber mindestens genauso herausragend ist, dass von amerikanischer Seite auch Studierende nach Deutschland kommen und das für ein ganzes Jahr. Das passiert sehr sehr selten, die Amerikaner gehen normalerweise deutlich kürzer, also ein ganzes Jahr ist wirklich viel. Sie haben ja eigentlich gerne da mal so einen Sommerkurs in Europa oder einem anderen Land, gerne nehmen sie auch ihre eigenen Lehrkräfte mit, um einfach woanders zu unterrichten. Aber dass sich amerikanische Studierende darauf einlassen, ein gesamtes Jahr ihrer Studienzeit im Ausland und in Deutschland zu verbringen, das ist selten und auch die Zahlen, die wir hier haben, sind ziemlich groß. Normalerweise ist das immer mal so eine Hand voll und hier sitzt also deutlich zweistellig. Das finde ich ziemlich gut so. Und die Programme mit China laufen anders, aber auch sehr sehr erfolgreich.
Wir haben also vor allem sehr viele chinesische Studierende, die nach Lübeck kommen und hier mit ihren Abschluss erwerben. Das sind aber nur zwei. Wir haben auch noch Kooperationen mit Indien und mit anderen Ländern usw. Aber die strategischen Partner das sind wirklich die USA und China. Und was ich so spannend finde an der Fachhochschule ist, dass sie es geschafft haben, diese Doppelabschlussprogramme und diese gemeinsamen Studiengänge zu implementieren. Was eigentlich, wenn man die Internationalisierung des Studiums betrachtet, die Kür ist. Also das sind wirklich so Sonderprogramme und Sonderprojekte, die sehr aufwendig sind und dann auch sehr renommiert und extrem gut für die Studierenden. Der ganze Pflichtbereich, von dem wir sonst so sprechen, Erasmus und mal ein halbes Jahr in Spanien oder mal ein Praktikum in Dänemark oder so, das alles ist deutlich weniger vorhanden als gleich dieses ganz große Rad.
Doppelabschluss heißt, dass man dann sozusagen sowohl an der FH quasi sein Abschlusspapier bekommt, als auch von einer anderen Uni als vollwertig anerkanntes Bachelorstudium zumindest.
Richtig, genau.
Nur Bachelor, kein Master oder das auch?
Das gäbe es auch, bei uns sind es Bachelorprogramme.
Okay.
Das war die Internationalisierung.
Das war die Internationalisierung. Also vielleicht nochmal dazu, also Internationalisierung heißt viel Austausch, die eigenen Studenten ins Ausland schicken, von dort auch Studenten hierher bekommen. Also was ist Ziel der Sache? Also ist Ziel, eine globalere Ausbildung zu bieten, die mehr Chancen und vielleicht auch ganz andere Ansatzpunkte als ein traditionelles Studium macht? Hat es auch damit zu tun, dass man ausländische Studenten dafür erwärmen will, auch in Deutschland eine Karriere anzustreben? Was ist sozusagen die Triebfeder dieser Idee?
Alles. Alles was Sie genannt haben. Also die Idee ist wirklich, ich mag das nicht, wenn das so plakativ klingt, aber Studierende für den globalen Arbeitsmarkt auszubilden, das ist natürlich sehr groß und ein sehr hehres Ziel, aber prinzipiell wirklich unseren Studierenden die Möglichkeit eröffnen, zumindest in beiden Ländern den Abschluss erworben zu haben und da vertiefte Kenntnisse zu haben. Es ist eine absolute Erweiterung des Erfahrungshorizontes, das würde man auch ohne den Doppelabschluss hinbekommen, aber es ist natürlich nochmal eine Zusatzqualifikation, die man hat. Es ist auch für den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt hoch interessant, wenn man diese Erfahrung gemacht hat und wenn man das nachweisen kann und es ist auch umgekehrt für uns sehr sehr gut, wenn internationale Studierende an unsere Hochschule kommen und mit den Studierenden in Kontakt kommen, die vielleicht selber nicht ins Ausland gehen. Also auch dort eine Internationalisierung vorzunehmen.
Aber ich muss nochmal sagen, an der Fachhochschule Lübeck bezieht sich Internationalisierung wirklich sehr konkret auf diese internationalen Studiengänge. Es ist nicht so ausgeprägt in anderen Bereichen Internationalisierung des Curriculums außerhalb dieser Studiengänge oder Internationaler Campus oder all das. Also das sind wirklich diese Kürprogramme, die wir da laufen haben.
Ich erinnere mich vor kurzer Zeit, das war glaube ich sogar auch eine Meldung des Stifterverbandes, dass so die Konversionszahlen von ausländischen Studenten, die hier in Deutschland studieren, vielleicht auch mehr als nur ein Jahr, zu wünschen übrig lassen, dass viele sich nicht unbedingt dafür erwärmen können, in Deutschland dann auch wirklich zu bleiben und hier eine Karriere anzustreben in der Wissenschaft.
Was meinen Sie jetzt, dass nicht so viele ausländische Studierende nach Deutschland kommen oder dass sie nicht bleiben?
Dass die Quote derer, die gekommen sind, die auch wirklich hier bleiben und in Deutschland ihr Wissen einbringen, dass die sehr viel geringer ist als in anderen Ländern. Also dass zum Beispiel Studenten, die in die USA gehen sehr viel höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, dort auch zu bleiben.
Also ohne dass ich jetzt die konkreten Zahlen im Kopf habe, aber meiner Ansicht nach dreht sich das ziemlich gut. Also die Gesetze in Deutschland waren vormals noch ein bisschen arg restriktiv, um wirklich hier zu bleiben. Ich erinnere mich an meine eigene Promotionszeit, da hatte ich eine Kollegin aus Kroation und die musste wirklich mit ihrer letzten Prüfung dann wieder ausreisen. Das ist etwas, was die USA ganz anders gehandhabt haben und wo Deutschland nachgezogen hat. Also wenn man hier seinen Abschluss gemacht hat, dann darf man ein Jahr lang bleiben, um auf Arbeitssuche zu gehen beispielsweise. Da sind die Gesetze jetzt teilweise deutlich weniger restriktiv als in den USA beispielsweise, die in dem gleichen Zeitraum umgekehrt ihre Gesetze angezogen haben. Also das hat die deutsche Politik erkannt und da hat sie auch einiges für getan. Es gibt auch bestimmte Programme, die versuchen, die Personen dann als Arbeitskräfte in Deutschland zu halten. Es wird immer dann tatsächlich schwierig, wenn die Studierenden kein Deutsch können. Das ist nach wie vor so, weil sie dann in klein- und mittelständischen Unternehmen beispielsweise selten eine Chance haben.
Ich weiß jetzt auch gerade, was ich zitiert habe, nämlich den Hochschulbildungsreport 2020 wie das heißt. Also jetzt für 2015 ist auch tatsächlich internationale Bildung ein Schwerpunkt und wenn ich jetzt auch noch richtig erinnere, war dann auch sozusagen einer der Schlüsse, die daraus gezogen wurden, dass offensichtlich in Deutschland die Begleitung dieser internationalen Studenten dann zu spät einsetzt. Also dass man sozusagen erst so gegen Ende des Studiums meint, achja übrigens kannst du dir auch vorstellen hier zu bleiben? Es dann aber sozusagen schon nicht mehr richtig greift. Versus eben einer Strategie, wie sie manche andere Länder fahren, die eben quasi von Tag eins an das schon versuchen zu begleiten?
Ja jetzt muss man aber sagen, dass die deutschen Hochschulen generell die Studierenden weniger begleitet haben in der Vergangenheit als andere Länder. Wir sind ja in einem Land ohne Studiengebühren und da hat es sich dann doch sehr auf diese Freiheit beschränkt und auf die Selbstbestimmtheit und auch auf die Selbstorganisation. Das ist ja ein ganz großes Thema an deutschen Hochschulen, man muss sich das Studium und alles selbst organisieren. Und das sogenannte Karrierezentren eröffnet haben, das ist meiner Ansicht nach auch noch nicht so wahnsinnig lange der Fall. DAS ist inzwischen gut etabliert und das gibt es auf breiter Ebene, dass Hochschulen sich so ein Karrierezentrum eingerichtet haben und dann war Jahre lang die Forderung, da stimme ich vollkommen zu, der internationalen Studierenden, dass sie dort auch Angebote haben wollen.
Und das ist das eine. Also quasi beim Übergang vom Studium in den Beruf, mehr Angebote auch für internationale Studierende, das haben die Hochschulen erkannt, da ziehen die auch nach. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so einfach, aber das erfolgt jetzt auch. Das andere, was Sie gesagt haben, diese Betreuung dieser internationalen Studierenden von Anfang an ist ein Thema, dem sich der DHD auch massiv gewidmet hat, und wo sie auch eigene Projekte hatten, wo man sie schon bevor sie anfangen zu studieren abholt und auch in das deutsche System erst mal einführt. Das muss man ja auch erst mal verstehen, wie das funktioniert. Also ich glaube es stimmt, dass diese Begleitung kompakter und komplexer sein könnte.
Dann will ich gern auf den zweiten Schwerpunkt einsteigen. Und das ist ja auch sagen wir mal eine Geschichte, die auch jetzt für den Stifterverband besonders interessant war in letzter Zeit, E-Learning oder sagen wir mal generell so eine Digitalisierungsaspekt, inwiefern ist jetzt E-Learning ein besonderer Schwerpunkt der FH Lübeck?
Also er ist einer von drei Schwerpunkten an der Fachhochschule Lübeck, es gibt diesen Bereich schon sehr lange. Das  finde ich auch sehr spannend daran, nämlich seit 1997. Und wir haben an der Fachhochschule Lübeck zum einen, um mal auf die Strukturen kurz einzugehen, anhand derer man das vielleicht ganz gut erklären kann, wir haben einen beauftragten des Präsidiums für E-Learning und Weiterbildung und wir haben ein Institut für Lerndienstleistungen, was ein Inneninstitut ist der Fachhochschule und wir haben eine 100%ige Tochter der Fachhochschule Lübeck, eine GmbH on Campus GmbH, die Studiengänge und Weiterbildungsangebote und einzelne Module entwickelt und vertreibt und vermarktet. Das heißt wir haben einen wirklich hier sehr großen und intensiv arbeitenden Bereich, der schon sehr früh auf den Markt getreten ist.
Und sich überlegt hat, wie man die Digitalisierung vorantreiben kann und der auch in meinen Augen mit immer neuen Ideen sich weiterentwickelt und es dabei schafft, das sind jetzt ein paar Schlagwörter so, aber der es dabei schafft, wirklich aus der Projektebene zu kommen, also nicht nur Projekte durchzuführen, sondern auch tatsächlich in die Nachhaltigkeit einzusteigen. Also seit 1997 gibt es diesen Bereich, der ist stetig gewachsen, inzwischen haben wir dort rund 70 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, die da tätig sind. Also das ist wirklich für eine Hochschule unserer Größe ein ganz ganz großer Bereich.
Was fasst denn das jetzt eigentlich konkret zusammen? Also was versteht man denn unter E-Learning? Also ich meine, es ist ein schöner Begriff so, ja wir lernen und jetzt mal mit E so, aber was ist sozusagen am A-Learning so verbesserungswürdig gewesen in dieser Perspektive, dass man da nochmal die elektronischen Möglichkeiten besonders betonen möchte?
Also das würde ich gerne trennen. Ich würde zum einen erst mal abstreiten, dass die Präsenzlehre verbesserungswürdig war und man deswegen E-Learning erfunden hat, das ist glaube ich nicht der Punkt, sondern man hat einfach neue Technologien und neue Kommunikationsformen mit aufgegriffen in die Aufgabe, die Hochschulen haben. So bei uns an der Fachhochschule bezieht sich dieser E-Learning-Bereich und deswegen ist es auch der Beauftragte für E-Learning und Weiterbildung auf eine andere Zielgruppe, als die der Präsenzstudierenden oder wir nennen das die traditionellen Studierenden, nämlich es sind vor allem diejenigen, die berufsbegleitend studieren oder die aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht in der Präsenzlehre oder nicht präsent sein können. Sei es durch familiäre Bedingungen oder eben weil sie im Beruf sind oder weil sie nicht vor Ort sind, weil sie von woanders herkommen oder wie auch immer.
Das heißt es ist auch keine Konkurrenz zu der Präsenzlehre, sondern bei uns hat sich hier ein Bereich aufgebaut, der sich sehr sehr stark der berufsbegleitenden Ausbildung und der Weiterbildung widmet. Das heißt nicht, dass es diesen anderen Bereich nicht gibt, wo man in der Präsenzlehre auch noch online Angebote schafft und blended-learning Angebote schafft oder das ganze digital unterstützt, das gibt es auch, aber der Hauptschwerpunkt liegt tatsächlich auf der berufsbegleitenden Ausbildung und auf der Weiterbildung.
Das schafft dann auch eine andere Zugänglichkeit. Also höre ich da jetzt auch raus, dass das quasi ein Angebot ist für Leute, die sonst aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht diese Präsenzlehre auch voll mitziehen können?
Richtig.
Schließt das auch Behinderung mit ein?
Ja.
Ja wobei ich jetzt eigentlich es sehr schade fände, wenn man behaupten würde, dass man mit einer Behinderung bei uns nicht vor Ort studieren könnte, ja also.
Ja nun, aber es ist ja eine Einschränkung auf jeden Fall?
Ja.
Das heißt E-Learning heißt jetzt zunächst einmal eine Erweiterung es normalen Programms und die Nutzung digitaler Medien, um Lernen besser mit anderen Dingen kombinieren zu können oder um Einschränkungen zu kompensieren?
Genau, das hat eine andere Zielgruppe.
Was für Techniken kommen da jetzt konkret zur Anwendung? Wie entwickelt man das? Was ist da sozusagen die Strategie? Also wir sollten vielleicht nochmal kurz einflechten, das war ja dann auch mehr oder weniger dann gleich zu Beginn Ihrer Zeit als Präsidentin so, dass der Stifterverband einen Wettbewerb ausgeschrieben hat, wo sich die FH Lübeck auch drauf beworben hat. Der Strategiewettbewerb Hochschulbildung und Digitalisierung. Das war vom Stifterverband gemeinsam mit der Heinz Nixdorf Stiftung ausgeschrieben. Und da ging es ja darum, verschiedene Digitalisierungsstrategien zu fördern.
Ja.
Wie ist da die FH Lübeck reingekommen und wie hat sozusagen die schon existierende Strategie dann auf diesen Wettbewerb gepasst?
Dann sage ich nochmal kurz was zur grundsätzlichen Digitalisierungsstrategie an der Fachhochschule Lübeck. Das finde ich ist nämlich ein ganz schönes Bild. Die beruht auf zwei Eckpfeilern, damit haben die 1997 begonnen und daran halten sie bis heute fest. Nämlich zum einen, dass es sich um eine Öffnung der Hochschule handelt, das kann man so als Schlagwort sehen offene Hochschule, das heißt die Öffnung für, wie wir eben schon besprochen haben, für die nicht traditionellen Studierenden, als beispielsweise berufsbegleitend oder aus anderen Gründen nicht an der Präsenzlehre teilnehmend, das ist das eine, der eine Eckpfeiler. Der zweite Eckpfeiler ist, dass von Anfang an gesagt wurde, unsere Fachhochschule allein ist zu klein, um hier ein umfangreiches Angebot nachhaltig starten zu können. Wir können zwar mal ein Projekt gewinnen oder wir können mal, wie bei dieser Ausschreibung mitmachen, aber wir müssen ja überlegen, wie wir nach Ende der Projektlaufzeit das Thema weiterführen können und wie wir das nachhaltig gestalten können und deswegen sagt unser Beauftragter für E-Learning und Weiterbildung Professor Granow, der sagt immer so schön, der erste Weg 1997 führte nicht ins Netz, sondern er führte in die Netzwerke, also in die Kooperation.
Das ist also ein ganz ganz wichtiger Eckpfeiler für uns und da ist unheimlich viel entstanden und sehr durchdacht vorangetrieben worden, an Studiengängen, an Weiterbildungen, an Kooperationen.
Also nicht nur Netzwerke mit anderen Hochschulen, sondern auch mit ganz anderen Organisationsformen
Auch mit anderen Organisationsformen und vor allem, was ich schön finde, dass hier wirklich sehr vorbehaltlos gedacht wird. Und man tatsächlich sehr themenorientiert guckt, wo sind jetzt die richtigen Partner für uns angesiedelt. Und zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt auch Projekte im Bereich der Weiterbildung, wo über Kooperationen mit Volkshochschulen nachgedacht wird. Also wir sind da wirklich sehr offen in alle Bereiche, da wo es einem guttut versuchen wir zu kooperieren. Und die Ausschreibung, die Sei eben erwähnt haben vom Stifterverband und von der Heinz Nixdorf Stiftung da wurde die Strategie quasi einen Schritt weiterentwickelt, und zwar zusammengebracht mit dem anderen Schwerpunkt der Fachhochschule Lübeck, der Internationalisierung. Und das ist auch etwas, was ich ganz großartig finde, weil ich das, als ich mich auf diese Stelle beworben habe, habe ich diese drei Schwerpunkte gesehen und habe gedacht, die sind ja wirklich fantastisch, sie laufen aber noch ganz schön parallel.
Es wäre gut, sie weiter zusammenzuführen und dafür muss man auch gar nicht viel machen, weil das wirklich der ganz authentisch passende nächste Schritt ist. Und bei dieser Ausschreibung wurde tatsächlich das gemacht, da wurde also überlegt, jetzt sollten wir uns für eine weitere Zielgruppe öffnen und das sind die der internationalen Studierenden. Und die Idee dahinter ist jetzt wieder den selben Gedanken zu nehmen, nämlich schön jetzt haben wir hier eine Anschubfinanzierung gewonnen, um das hinterher nachhaltig weiter betreiben zu können, brauchen wir wieder Partner und das ist auch jetzt wieder der erste Weg. Also wir besetzen eine Stelle, einen Wissenschaftsmanager, der das ganze koordiniert für uns und vorantreibt und für uns nach internationalen Partnern sucht und Zielgruppenanalysen macht. Guckt, was wird eigentlich benötigt und gebraucht und vor allem, wie können wir unsere Angebote dann auf diese Zielgruppen zuschneidern.
Und ein international passendes Angebot zu machen ist einfach sehr sehr viel mehr als bestehende Texte ins Englische zu übersetzen, sondern man muss wirklich gucken, was wird dort gebraucht, wie wird dort gelernt, wie wird dort gelehrt, was für Beispiele, was für Inhalte gibt es und dann daraufhin das Ganze zuzuschneidern. Auch hier wären wir wieder zu klein, wenn wir es alleine machen würden, das heißt wir suchen jetzt nach Partnern.
Was sind das dann für Partner?
Das sind dann andere Hochschulen jetzt erst mal vor allem.
Also die quasi dann auf dasselbe System, die selbe Systematik einschwenken könnten, ohne alles doppelt entwickeln zu müssen?
Richtig oder wo man sagen kann, also wir haben eine Lehrkraft an der Fachhochschule die kann dieses Modul ganz besonders gut und sie haben die Expertise dort. Das heißt die machen ein Modul, wir machen ein Modul, wir machen das zusammen. Wir haben die technische Expertise, wir haben die ganze Infrastruktur, um das zu machen und dann gucken wir, wie wir zusammen hier einen Studiengang oder eine Weiterbildung oder auch erst mal einzelne Module aufbauen.
Der Vorschlag der stieß ja dann auf Gegenliebe und der Wettbewerb hat dann unter anderem die FH Lübeck gefördert.
Richtig.
Das geht jetzt sozusagen auch schon los?
Richtig, genau. Also da ist, ich weiß nicht, ob die Ausschreibung jetzt gerade läuft oder schon abgeschlossen ist, also die Stelle ist noch nicht besetzt, aber das ist sozusagen der erste Schritt, um dann jemanden zu haben, der das ganze weiter vorantreiben kann.
Also auch hier erst mal nicht ins Netz, sondern ins Netzwerk?
Richtig.
Aber letztlich wird ja dann, also konkret muss ja dann auch was digitales bei herauskommen. Ich meine, es klingt ja jetzt auch erst mal sehr nahe liegend, ich meine, vorher sagten wir, E-Learning wendet sich vor allem an Leute, die sozusagen in irgendeiner Form in der Ferne sind, das gilt natürlich dann für die internationalen Studenten nochmal im Besonderen. Heißt das, dass man quasi ein Angebot schafft, um die internationalen Studenten, die dann irgendwann mal ein Jahr da sein werden, auch schon vorher und nachher einzubinden oder wie muss man das jetzt denken?
Nein, also was wir weniger haben ist quasi diese Digitalisierung für bereits bestehende Programme, in denen wir einen Austausch haben. Sondern es ist wirklich eine neue Zielgruppe. Was aber durchgängig bei all den Angeboten ist, die wir machen, ist, man kann Zertifikate bei den Weiterbildungen oder Credit Points bei den Studiengängen erwerben und man hat eine Durchlässigkeit zwischen den Onlineangeboten und den Präsenzangeboten. Also was durchaus eine Hoffnung ist, ist, dass wir die internationalen Studierenden über unser Onlineangebot dazu bewegen können, tatsächlich auch mal in Präsenz an der Fachhochschule Lübeck zu studieren. Und da kann man sich die Sachen auch anrechnen lassen. Also wir haben eine Durchlässigkeit zwischen den Systemen. Sie können quasi das was sie in der Präsenzlehre gemacht haben auch auf die Onlinestudiengänge anrechnen lassen und umgekehrt, wenn Sie doch von einem ins andere wechseln möchten.
Und wenn wir es schaffen, noch eine größere Bekanntheit in bestimmten Regionen zu erreichen und vielleicht die Studierenden dazu ermutigen, dann vielleicht den Master in Lübeck zu machen oder einen anderen Studiengang in Lübeck zu machen, dann haben wir damit unser Ziel auch ein Stück weit erreicht. Ist also auch eine Rekrutierungsmaßnahme unter anderem.
Was ist denn so die E-Learning Realität? Wie sieht das zum Beispiel bei dieser beruflichen Weiterbildung aus? Also konkret, was ändert sich im Lernvorgang für diese Studenten?
Sie meinen jetzt im Vergleich zu, wenn ich im Klassenzimmer sitze?
Ja genau. Zu den normalen Präsenzgeschichten.
Also da sind natürlich die ganzen Vorteile, dass Sie selber entscheiden, wann Sie lernen und wo Sie lernen und in welcher Geschwindigkeit. Also das ist ganz entscheidend. Sie haben Ihre Dokumente und die Arbeitsmaterialien und alle das, das haben Sie online. Das sind auch verschiedene Formen. Also das sind Videos oder Animationen oder ganz verschiedene Angebote. Was aber ähnlich ist, wenn nicht vielleicht sogar ein bisschen intensiver ist die Betreuung des ganzen. Das denkt man so erst mal nicht. Kommt auch drauf an, was Sie jetzt meinen? Also jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen differenzieren zwischen den unterschiedlichen Formen. Also vielleicht fangen wir doch nochmal andersherum an. Wenn Sie beispielsweise einfach eine E-Lecture besuchen, dann ist das eine Vorlesung im Netz.
Das ist jetzt nicht doll anders, außer dass Sie eben das von zu Hause aus machen können oder wo immer Sie gerade sind und wann immer Sie wollen.
Also mit so einem Livevideostreaming.
Zum Beispiel. Dann haben wir die Moocs, das sind auch Veranstaltungen, die Sie kostenfrei und von überall her besuchen können. Da ist ein bisschen Austausch gegeben. Da können Sie sich auf Plattformen mit anderen Mooc-Teilnehmern austauschen beispielsweise, da ist aber keine sehr intensive Betreuung.
Also Massive Open Online Course, wem der Begriff nicht …
Genau, also nicht die Kuh, sondern dann MOOC. Da ist die Betreuung ein bisschen stärker gegeben, als jetzt rein bei einer E-Lecture, aber es ist immer noch recht betreuungsarm. Es wird ja auch kostenfrei angeboten.
Diese Moocs sind dann auch wirklich für alle?
Für alle.
Also da kann jeder, ich könnte mich da reinklinken, wenn ich Lust hätte?
Ja jetzt sofort.
Aber die anderen Sachen sind sozusagen speziell jetzt nur für den jeweiligen Studentenkreis.
Wenn Sie jetzt weitergehen. Also wenn Sie beispielsweise einen Onlinestudiengang machen, dann kommen Sie in einen geschützten Raum. Da müssen Sie sich anmelden. Da werden Sie zum Beispiel auch Mitglied der Hochschule, anders als wenn Sie eine Mooc besuchen. Da machen Sie richtig den Studiengang mit. Da ist die Betreuung dann zum Beispiel auch sehr viel höher. Da können Sie auch Zertifikate erwerben, wenn es eine Weiterbildung ist oder Sie können einen ganzen Abschluss machen. Sie können Ihren Bachelor oder Ihren Master machen. Und da ist natürlich die Betreuung eine ganz andere, da ist aber auch der Aufwand ein größerer. Da müssen Sie also richtig arbeiten.
Was ist so die Motivation, diese Moocs zu machen? Das so weit zu öffnen?
Das ist der Bildungsgedanke. Also ich finde das ganz interessant, weil bevor ich nach Lübeck gegangen bin habe ich gedacht, was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder für eine wilde Idee? Wir stellen hier, so habe ich mir das vorgestellt, wir stellen hier eine Vorlesung in den Raum und schreiben, das macht Harvard und schon klicken sich aus der ganzen Welt Millionen von Leuten ein und plötzlich sagen sie alle, wir sind Harvardstudenten, das kann ja eigentlich nicht gut sein. Und was mir hier Stück für Stück nahe gebracht wurde, das ist finde ich ein viel viel interessantere Gedanke, nämlich dass man sagt, das ist wirklich Bildung für alle, aber es soll keinesfalls einen Studiengang ersetzen. Es geht nicht darum, dass man sagt, die Leute können sich jetzt von überall her einloggen, und wenn sie das ganze durchgeguckt haben von A-Z dann sind sie perfekt ausgebildet. Sondern es ist einfach ein Angebot an alle, sich weiterzubilden, und zwar in dem Umfang, in dem man das möchte.
Und das finde ich einen interessanten Gedanken. Es ersetzt nicht das, was es bereits gibt, sondern es ist ein weiteres Angebot. Und damit locken wir Leute in den Hochschulraum und in die Themen und in die Bildung. Das finde ich …
Weil man sozusagen überhaupt auch erst mal angefixt wird so mit, hier du kannst dir ein Studium vielleicht nicht vorstellen, so könnte das sein.
Bzw. wenn Leute jetzt aus anderen Gründen, entweder weil sie jetzt keine besondere Karrieremotivation haben oder aus anderen Gründen einfach an so einem Studium nicht teilnehmen können oder wollen, können sie sich sehr wohl eben diese Inhalte auch verinnerlichen und in ihrem Leben umsetzen, auch wenn da jetzt vielleicht kein amtlicher Stempel unten drunter ist, aber es schadet ja auch nichts, das zu wissen.
Richtig.
Unsere Erfahrungen zeigen auch, dass die Personen, die an so einem Mooc teilnehmen, gar nicht unbedingt interessiert daran sind, ein Zertifikat zu erwerben. Die sind einfach neugierig.
Die wollen einfach hören und lernen.
Genau, und ich stelle mir das so ein bisschen vor wie einen Zeitungsleser. Weil ja auch viele an den Moocs kritisieren, dass man hohe Abbrecherquoten hat oder wie auch immer, man hat verdammt hohe Zahlen und hinterher brechen 99% ab. Die Frage ist, was ist daran so schlimm? Ich vergleiche das immer gern mit einem Zeitungsleser, der hat ja auch die Zeitung nur dann nicht richtig gelesen, wenn er sie von Anfang bis Ende durchgelesen hat und jeden einzelnen Artikel, sondern man sucht sich das raus, was einen interessiert. Heute ist es der Sportteil, morgen ist es der Wirtschaftsteil, immer ist es die Politik, also was weiß ich. Also man sucht sich die Teile raus, die einen interessieren und das liest man und hinterher ist man ein bisschen klüger. Und das finde ich einen genau passenden Weg für Bildungsinstitutionen.
Und nebenbei macht man natürlich auch ein bisschen Werbung für seine Hochschule?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich denke, das war auch so die primäre Motivation. Ich meine, die amerikanischen, gerade die großen Eliteuniversitäten sind ja relativ schnell auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen und jetzt kann man ja komplette Studiengänge im Prinzip aus der Ferne mitverfolgen kostenlos.
Bekommt dann aber das Zertifikat erst mal nicht.
Nein, man kriegt kein Zertifikat, aber wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwo auf diesem Planeten wohne und ich bin zumindest in der Lage, mir eine Internetverbindung legen zu lassen, die schnell genug ist, um diese Inhalte überhaupt erst mal zu mir zu bekommen, dann habe ich ja dieses Wissen. Das ist ja dann sozusagen auch schon mal was wert, es geht ja nicht nur um Zertifikate und Stempel in diesem Leben. Sondern wenn man sagt, naja ich habe jetzt vielleicht keinen Zettel, aber ich kann dir diese Vorlesung auswendig runterbeten.
Ich habe einen Mooc gehört, ich habe eine Zeitung gelesen, ich habe ein Buch gelesen, toll.
Also das hat Zukunft?
Ich glaube ja. Solange man es nicht verwechselt mit einem Studiengang oder mit anderen Formen des Studierens. Sondern einfach als ein Zusatzangebot sieht, was aber völlig logisch in den Ausbildungsgedanken passt. Und in Lübeck wollen wir massiv voranschreiten, wir haben jetzt 2013 unser erstes Mooc gestartet im Bereich Marketing und wir wollen bis 2020 40 Stück anbieten. Also das ist schon ein Wachstumsmarkt auch.
Jetzt hatten wir schon gesagt, als Beispiel für wie man sich das vorstellen muss mit dem E-Learning, also es gibt Materialien im Netz, es gibt die Vorlesung im Netz und es gibt die besondere Form dieser Moocs. Gibt es noch weitere Dinge, die man erwähnen müsste in dem Zusammenhang?
Na die Austauschplattformen natürlich. Und dann …
Wer tauscht sich da womit und mit wem aus?
Studierende und Lehrende.
Also quasi ein Social Network?
Ja vielleicht. Also da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Formen. Das hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab, was Sie für einen Studiengang wählen. Und was man nicht vergessen darf, dass bei unseren Onlinestudiengängen tatsächlich auch eine Präsenzlehre erforderlich ist. Bei manchen Studiengängen beispielsweise müssen Sie einfach auch mal im Labor stehen, das können Sie nicht alles virtuell machen. Man kann schon ziemlich viel virtuell machen. Also es gibt auch Plattformen, wo sich Architekten und Bauingenieure gemeinsam austauschen und virtuell Gebäude bauen und ähnliches, da kann man schon ziemlich viel machen, aber manche Sachen müssen Sie eben doch in Präsenz machen. Das ist etwas was mir auch sehr sehr gut gefällt, weil dadurch, dass es berufsbegleitend ist bei uns, findet diese Präsenzlehre immer freitags und samstags statt. Wir haben also nochmal eine ganz andere Auslastung von unserer Hochschule.
Also wenn sich viele ins Wochenende verabschieden von unseren regulär Studierenden, dann kommt die andere Gruppe und bevölkert wieder die Hochschule selber. Das finde ich extrem gut.
Austauschplattform, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also ist das dann so was wie Facebook oder was wird da ausgetauscht?
Also wir haben eine Plattform bei uns, die heißt Moodle, wo man sich einloggen kann und wo man die Lerntätigkeiten stattfindet, wie das ganz konkret in den einzelnen Studiengängen aussieht, das kann ich gar nicht beschreiben.
Ja Moodle ist ja so eine OpenSource Social Network für Bildungsplattformen, also das kommt zum Einsatz?
Genau.
Was ist denn mit so was wie Facebook? Also so Social Networks, also die populären Social Networks spielen ja auch an Universitäten eine große Rolle. Ich meine gerade bei Facebook ist das ja quasi sozusagen auch die Geschichte. Ertappt man sich dabei, dass solche Netzwerke auch wirklich Teil des Workflow werden oder Teil der Kommunikation sind? Und ist das schlimm?
Also Facebook und die ähnlichen die sind ja Fluch und Segen zugleich. Das ist etwas, was enorm betreuungsintensiv ist. Wenn Sie auf Facebook oder wo immer mal eine Weile nicht tätig sind, dann verlieren Sie den Nutzer und sind nicht mehr interessant und nicht mehr relevant. Das ist etwas, was man sich sehr genau überlegen muss, ob man das als Hochschule leisten kann. Ich brauche dafür ja Personal, ich brauche ja Leute, die das einrichten, die das pflegen, die die Inhalte rein stellen, die die Kommunikation mit überwachen. Das kann extrem nützlich sein, weil wir über die klassischen E-Mail Verteiler beispielsweise unsere Studierenden nicht erreichen. Das muss man einfach mal sagen, die bekommen alle eine eigene Hochschul-E-Mail-Adresse, nutzen aber ihre eigene, vergessen die Weiterleitungen, da kommen wir nicht weit mit. Das ist irgendwie schon veraltetes Medium habe ich fast das Gefühl.
Ja gut, man könnte ja dann immer noch ihre E-Mail Adresse verwenden.
Wie meinen Sie?
Also nicht unbedingt eine eigene an der Hochschule geben, sondern in der Annahme, dass heutzutage jeder eigentlich eine E-Mail Adresse hat, davon kann man ausgehen.
Richtig, da müssten sie die uns aber geben. Das ist wieder so der Punkt, wir müssen es einpflegen. Das würde alles gehen, aber was ich sagen möchte ist, dass Facebook und ähnliches ein sehr sehr guter Weg wäre, die Studierenden zu erreichen, aber es ist arbeits- und personalintensiv und bei Facebook versteht auch keiner, dass zum Beispiel Samstag und Sonntag nicht gearbeitet wird oder dann vielleicht nach 18 Uhr nicht mehr. Da ist eine ganz andere Erwartungshaltung dahinter. Und ich denke, wenn man in den Bereich einsteigt, dann muss man sich sehr genau überlegen, dass wenn jemand drei Wochen im Urlaub ist, der unsere Facebookseite pflegt, die nicht einfach brach liegen darf. Das ist dann doch relativ groß. Das heißt an den kleinen Hochschulen, wo ich bisher tätig war, haben wir davon abgesehen, uns auf diese Netzwerke einzuschalten, weil wir gedacht haben, wir machen uns da lächerlich. Wenn dann plötzlich die selbe Meldung für 10-14 Tage steht. Weil wir einfach personell nicht so ausgestattet sind, dass da jemand sich ständig drum kümmert.
Ich meine es macht natürlich auch in dem Moment erst Sinn, in dem man sich auch etwas davon verspricht. Also nicht nur dieses, haha wir sind jetzt auch bei Facebook und man kann uns liken. Sondern es muss ja sozusagen auch ein Versprechen damit verbunden sein, wenn wir diese Arbeit da hinein investieren können und wollen, was wollen wir dann darüber auch verbessern? Also was soll dann sozusagen auch passieren? Geht es darum, Support zu leisten, geht es darum, einfach die eigenen News und Angebote mehr unters Volk zu kriegen. Das muss ja sozusagen auch wirklich ein erkennbarer Mehrwert sein?
Also den würde ich schon deutlich sehen. Ich kann mir das zum Beispiel auch vorstellen, dass man über diese Seite zu bestimmten Themen auch Ressourcen sparen könnte, weil Studierende sich untereinander weiterhelfen beispielsweise das kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen. Unsere Informationen unters Volk zu bringen, sehr kurzfristig Informationen unters Volk zu bringen. Den nutzen würde ich schon sehen, bloß der Aufwand ist für eine Hochschule wirklich sehr sehr hoch und das überlegt man sich dann mehrfach. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir lange noch drumherum kommen, um Facebook vielleicht, aber um andere Formen vielleicht nicht. Da sind wir in der Kommunikation doch teilweise noch sagen wir mal mit sozialen Netzwerken ein bisschen hinterher. Wir haben eine interne Internetseite geschaltet, wo ich hoffe, dass die vielleicht die Funktion auch ein Stück weit mit abfangen kann.
Jetzt meinten Sie ja, das ist ja jetzt sozusagen alles nicht neues, Sie sind ja dahin gekommen, weil es da schon diese Ansätze gibt und das auch schon seit längerer Zeit, von daher weiß ich nicht, ob Sie die richtige Adressatin sind für die Frage, aber ich frage mich natürlich, inwiefern das jetzt auch ein Kampf mit sich gezogen hat, diesen Weg überhaupt zu gehen, also erlebt es ja auch häufig, dass Digitalisierung nicht notwendig gesehen wird oder vielleicht auch als Bedrohung einer existierenden Struktur. Wissen Sie, ob es ähnliche Schwierigkeiten auch an der FH gegeben hat oder noch gibt? Überhaupt was erfordert es auch im Verbund mit dem Land, der Stadt, solche Strategien voranzubringen?
Also angefangen mit der Digitalisierung haben wir an der Fachhochschule ja im Jahr 1997. Ich kann da nicht viel zu sagen, ich würde auch hoffen, dass wenn es Schwierigkeiten gab, dass die dann bis heute vergessen sind. Was ich an der Fachhochschule Lübeck erlebe ist, dass sie dort sehr sehr offen sind für Innovationen und dass sie in den 90er Jahren nicht nur diesen Onlinebereich ins Leben gerufen haben, sondern eben auch die beiden anderen Schwerpunkte mit den internationalen Studiengängen und mit dem Technologie- und Wissenstransferbereich, also dass sie dort generell innovativ unterwegs waren und offen unterwegs waren und so erlebe ich die Fachhochschule bis heute. Und das ist aber meiner Ansicht nach auch relativ typisch, das gehört ja zum Wesen von Hochschulen dazu, dass man sich neuem öffnet und dass man offen und kreativ bleibt.
Ich finde, dass sie das hier an der Fachhochschule einfach so besonders klug hinbekommen haben, weil sie es nicht nur in Projekte, sondern eben auch in Strukturen gedacht haben und gleich Strukturen geschaffen haben, die einfach helfen, am Ball zu bleiben. Also beispielsweise nicht eine Vizepräsidentschaft für das Thema, sondern einen Beauftragten, der nicht jetzt irgendwelchen Wahlperioden unterworfen ist. Ich denke also, ich würde jetzt mal sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es damals Startschwierigkeiten gab oder nicht, wenn dann sind sie vergessen. Es ist mir nichts übermittelt worden. Es wird nicht gesagt, ach ja damals 1997 da war ja auch die große Kampfabstimmung. Also das höre ich nicht mehr. Was ich wohl wahrnehme ist, dass sich die Welt so ein bisschen teilt in diejenigen, die verstehen, was dort tatsächlich abläuft. Sie haben ja vorhin auch zum Beispiel sehr darauf nochmal nachgehakt, wie so eine Lehrplattform, wie so ein Raum aussieht und wie man sich das vorstellen muss.
Und ich bin auch jemand, der klassisch studiert hat und nicht online und deswegen auch Schwierigkeiten hatte, ich muss das alles sehr mir aneignen. Und dann durch unsere Institute, durch unser Inneninstitut durchlaufen und mir mal zeigen lassen, wie das alles aussieht und was sie da für Räume und technische Möglichkeiten haben. Ich habe das selber auch nicht erlebt und ich glaube, es geht sehr vielen so, die das selber nicht erlebt haben und deswegen das zusätzlich neu lernen müssen und manche haben halt mehr Bereitschaft und Spaß daran, so etwas neu zu lernen und sich dem zu widmen. Und jetzt wachsen aber immer mehr Leute nach, für die das ganz selbstverständlich ist. Ich erlebe es so, dass es aber wie gesagt diesen Teil der Leute gibt, die damit nicht viel zu tun haben. Man muss noch nicht auch digital unterwegs sein. Man kann seine Vorlesungen nach wie vor klassisch präsent halten. Es gibt bei uns keine Verpflichtung, oder es gab keine Verpflichtungen, auch im E-Learning Bereich tätig zu sein.
Das hat sich geändert, seit einigen Jahren wird im Berufungsschreiben festgehalten, dass erwartet wird von neuberufenen Professorinnen und Professoren, dass sie sich an der Onlinelehre beteiligen und dass sie bereit sind, englischsprachige Lehre zu halten. Das sind also zwei Voraussetzungen, die die mit quasi auf den Weg bekommen und unterschreiben, wenn sie an der Fachhochschule Lübeck neu anfangen wollen. Insofern wird es sich immer mehr verfestigen, aber es ist natürlich so, dass wenn wir wie bei uns an der Fachhochschule einen Bereich haben, der so groß ist, ein Institut, eine GmbH, 70 Leute, Studiengänge, die nicht nur unsere eigenen Studiengänge sind, sondern auch noch Studiengänge von anderen Hochschulen vertreibt, Weiterbildungen vertreibt, teilweise auch mit Themen umgeht, die jetzt nicht zu unserem Fächerspektrum gehören, dass das für den einen oder anderen nicht ganz nah ist am eigenen Alltagsgeschäft. Das ist schon auch so. Aber das gehört ja dazu. Man kennt ja auch nicht alles, was die anderen Kollegen machen.
Aber ist schon interessant, dass es jetzt diese Anforderungen gibt an neue Professoren. Gerade diese Frage mit, wird aufgezeichnet oder nicht. Also überhaupt so diese Bereitschaft zu haben, sich permanent so einer Beobachtung quasi zu unterziehen. Das ist glaube ich etwas, was sich auch irgendwie ändern muss. Ich habe das auch häufiger erlebt, dass es ein totales Unverständnis gab für solche Maßnahmen, dass irgendwie Vorträge oder auch alle einzelnen Vorlesungen einfach grundsätzlich aufgezeichnet werden. Allein um schon mal auch Studenten die Gelegenheit zu bieten, wenn sie mal krank waren, einfach in irgendwas reinzuhören. Ich meine das ist ja ein riesen Gewinn an der Stelle. Ich denke auch, dass das Selbstverständnis sich da langsam ändert.
Ja und da finde ich das schon wirklich wieder gut gedacht, dass man das gleich in den Berufungsverhandlungen mit aufnimmt und dass man das in den Berufungsschreiben auch mit festhält. Und zwar wirklich diese beiden Punkte, englischsprachige Lehre und Onlinelehre.
Was mich jetzt auch nochmal interessieren würde ist dieser dritte Punkt, den Sie genannt haben. Technologie und Wissenstransfer, das kenne ich auch aus anderen Bereichen, wo viel geforscht wird vor allem. Raumfahrt etc., die sich alle darum bemühen, wie können denn sozusagen unsere Inhalte zum Beispiel in der Industrie genutzt werden. Wie muss man jetzt diesen Anspruch hier verstehen im Kontext der Fachhochschule?
Also die Fachhochschule Lübeck versteht sich auch als eine stark forschende Fachhochschule. Wir haben da einen weiteren Schwerpunkt wie gesagt und haben hier auch eine ähnliche Struktur wie im Onlinebereich. Also es gibt auch hier einen Beauftragten des Präsidiums für den Technologie- und Wissenstransferbereich, das ist Professor Wolf-Regett und wir haben auch hier verschiedene institutionelle Formen gegründet, also auch wieder zwei GmbHs, die für uns da tätig sind und die zum Beispiel Auftragsforschung durchführen können oder Projekte abwickeln können. Also Drittmittelakquise und dann Forschungsprojekte.
Also das GmbH ist die der Hochschule gehören?
Eine 100% und eine nicht ganz 100%, aber die beide zur Fachhochschule mit gehören, genau. Eine Projekt GmbH und eine Forschungs-GmbH. Das ist sozusagen eine Struktur und die andere Struktur ist, dass wir neun Kompetenzzentren aufgebaut haben. Unter Kompetenzzentren verstehen wir Bereiche, in denen sich mehrere Professorinnen und Professoren zusammentun, die können also sehr wohl fachbereichsübergreifend sein, das wird sogar sehr befürwortet und die dann an ähnlichen Themen arbeiten und dort quasi ihre Kompetenzen zusammenführen und mit Partnern aus der Wirtschaft Forschung durchführen oder auch Transferleistungen durchführen. Und das läuft ebenfalls seit den 90er Jahren, dass dieses aufgebaut wird. Die Kompetenzzentren wechseln auch mal.
Also wenn was weiß ich, Professorinnen oder Professoren weggehen oder sich anderen Schwerpunkten widmen, dann kann das auch sein, dass wir so ein Kompetenzzentrum dann mal wieder schließen und es wieder neu eröffnen, je nachdem wie sich die Fachhochschule auch weiterentwickelt. Aber prinzipiell haben wir hier ein sehr stabiles System, mit einem klaren Ansprechpartner für die Wirtschaft. Und mit klaren Ansprechpartnern für unsere internen Leute, wenn sie zum Beispiel solche Anfragen bekommen aus der Wirtschaft und wissen möchten, wie sie das abwickeln können und wie sie das mit ihrer jetzigen Tätigkeit an der Fachhochschule verbinden können. Und so haben wir ein Netzwerk aufgebaut von ungefähr 200 Unternehmen in der Region und darüber hinaus, mit denen wir kooperieren und gemeinsame Aufträge und Aufgaben und Forschungsprojekte durchführen.
Wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen? Neun Kompetenzzentren, also worin unterscheiden die sich?
Von den Inhalten her.
Was sind das so zum Beispiel für Inhalte?
Beispielsweise haben wir ein Kompetenzzentrum das nennt sich KOSA, jetzt müsste ich lügen, wofür das direkt steht. Das ist ein Kommunikationskompetenzzentrum, wo wir Forschungsarbeiten und ganz konkrete Projekte durchführen, beispielsweise was Kommunikation unter Wasser angeht von – die haben da so ein hübsches Projekt, das ist aber schwer, das zu beschreiben, weil man es eigentlich als Bild sehen müsste. Sie haben so etwas, wie nennt man das, Mantas oder Rochen, also Roboter eigentlich, die unter Wasser schweben und miteinander kommunizieren können und mit denen man beispielsweise, wenn man Unterwassertätigkeiten durchführt, die Kommunikation durchführen kann. Aber das ist nur ein Projekt von vielen, das ist ein Kommunikationsprojekt, das stark begleitet wird vom Fachbereich Elektrotechnik und Informatik. Aber wo auch andere dran beteiligt sind.
Heißt übrigens Kommunikation Systeme Anwendung.
Richtig, wunderbar KOSA. Ich finde KOSA klingt immer so schön.
Ja auch so mit eigener Webpräsenz etc.
Natürlich ja genau. Und was das wirklich spannende ist, also was ich denke, was an der Fachhochschule Lübeck extrem gut gelöst ist, ist tatsächlich diese Kommunikation zwischen Wirtschaft und Hochschule. Das sind vollkommen unterschiedlich tickende Systeme, muss man einfach so sagen, die sprechen andere Sprachen. Und wenn Hochschulen und Wirtschaft zusammenarbeiten wollen und das wollen sie oft, dann brauchen sie jemanden, der für sie die Kommunikation übernimmt, der übersetzt, der dolmetscht, der zwischen den Systemen wandeln kann und die richtigen Ansprechpartner sowohl im einen Bereich als auch im anderen identifizieren kann und das ist bei uns durch diesen Technologie- und Wissenstransferbereich wirklich ganz hervorragend gelungen, dass jemand, der mit der Fachhochschule zusammenarbeiten möchte, nicht erst durch unterschiedliche Abteilungen geistern muss, bis er oder sie weiß, mit wem er endlich reden kann und für was und dann braucht er für Frage A einen Ansprechpartner und für die Frage B einen anderen.
Sondern wir haben da wirklich eine Abteilung, die das kommuniziert und in die Wege leitet. Und umgekehrt von uns aus auch Unternehmen anspricht und dort die Kooperation zustande bringt. Und was mir dabei ganz wichtig ist, ist dass das naturlich nicht einfach nur gemacht wird, weil es soviel Freude bereitet, das auch, aber es ist auch in ganz deutlicher Mehrwert für unsere Studierenden, weil in diesen Unternehmen beispielsweise dann Praktika oder Abschlussarbeiten dann auch angeboten werden können oder weil die gemeinsamen Forschungstätigkeiten dann auch in die Lehre einfließen und sie sehr gut auf das vorbereiten, was ihre zukünftigen Arbeitgeber von ihnen brauchen und wollen und wie die so arbeiten.
Forschung, also ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen simpler Blick, aber man denkt ja, Forschung ist eher eine Sache der Universität. Vielleicht können wir ja in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal so ein bisschen auf Ihr Selbstverständnis, was die Rolle der Fachhochschulen betrifft, eingehen. Also welchen Anteil hat Forschung, welche Bedeutung hat Forschung für den Hochschulbetrieb in der FH Lübeck?
Also Fachhochschulen haben den Auftrag, und der ist gesetzlich festgelegt, praxisorientierte Lehre und anwendungsorientierte Forschung. Das heißt Forschung steht in unserem Auftrag mit drin. Das ist jetzt nicht nur was, was sich die Fachhochschule Lübeck überlegt hat, sondern das gehört gesetzlich mit zu den Aufgaben und ist insofern abgegrenzt von den Universitäten, als dass bei den Universitäten es sich doch mehr auf Grundlagenforschung bezieht. Das ist also der Bereich, der mehr auf Grundlagen abzielt und bei uns soll es wirklich einen Anwendungsbezug haben. Das verschwimmt aber mehr und mehr und das bringt ja momentan auch diese Unruhe rein in das deutsche Hochschulsystem, wo hört denn jetzt der Bereich der Fachhochschule auf und beginnt der der Universität und umgekehrt.
Also ich erinnere mich an meine Zeit, als ich promoviert habe an einer Universität, da musste ich oder da gehörte es auch dazu, dass man sagt, na was ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Nutzen des ganzen? Da wurde auch nicht mehr geforscht um des Forschens Willen oder man musste sich sehr massiv durchsetzen, um zu sagen, ich forsche jetzt, weil das interessant ist. Und weil ich daran Interesse habe und ob das jemals einen Nutzen bringt oder nicht, das werden wir dann sehen. Das ist ja der ursprüngliche Gedanke, das wird auch immer schwieriger.
Gerade in Hinblick auf Drittmitteleinwerbung.
Richtig. Und das finde ich sehr sehr schade. Und an Fachhochschulen ist der Auftrag mit dieser Anwendungsorientierung sehr deutlich gegeben, aber dass es Forschung ist ist eben auch der Fall und wir haben bei uns an der Fachhochschule Lübeck auch promovierende beispielsweise. Wir haben kein eigenes Promotionsrecht, das haben Fachhochschulen noch nicht, aber wir können kooperative Promotionen durchführen, das können alle anderen auch. Wenn wir also eine Universität finden, die diese Promotionsarbeiten mitbetreut. Uns fehlt im Vergleich zu einer klassischen Universität der Mittelbau. Also die eigentlich Doktorandinnen und Doktoranden, die sehr viel von der Arbeit mit wegschleppen, sage ich mal so. Das haben wir bei uns sehr sehr wenig. Aber wir haben ein paar und das funktioniert sehr sehr gut. Also Forschung gehört bei Fachhochschulen absolut dazu, hat aber den anderen Fokus, die andere Ausrichtung.
Ist natürlich auch für die Unternehmen wirklich sehr interessant, an der Stelle auch die Verbindung dann einzugehen mit der FH und da spielen dann wieder die Kompetenzzentren mit rein. So dass man das besser kanalisieren kann.
Genau. Und wir haben einen fachlichen Schwerpunkt in Lübeck, das ist die Medizintechnik. Wir sitzen ja auch direkt Tür an Tür mit der Universität zu Lübeck und dem Klinikum, dem Universitätsklinikum Schleswig-Holstein und da sind auch Verbünde entstanden, wo wir gemeinsam zu dem Thema forschen und auch zu dem Thema lehren übrigens und auch gemeinsame Promotionen durchführen und das ist dann finde ich wirklich die perfekte Symbiose, da hat man dann alles gemeinsam. Wir haben ja auch Unternehmen vor Ort sitzen, wie beispielsweise Draeger, die sehr viele dieser Produkte vertreiben und auch entwickeln. Und die da mit involviert sind in einem gemeinsamen Dachverband, was wir haben. Also wir haben was gegründet, das heißt BioMedTec Wissenschaftscampus, da sind die Universität und die Fachhochschule und Fraunhofer Institut und Unternehmen alle unter einem Dach und haben das Ziel, da gemeinsame Felder. Wie beispielsweise die Medizintechnik von ihren unterschiedlichen Kompetenzen her zu beleuchten und voranzubringen und Nutzen daraus zu ziehen.
Diese, Sie hatten ja auch gerade noch erwähnt, Teil des Technologie- und Wissenstransfersystems sind zwei GmbHs. Warum nochmal was machen die genau und warum ist eine GmbH an der Stelle die richtige Organisationsform? Warum ist die erforderlich, welche Vorteile bietet die?
Also die Projekt GmbH ist eine GmbH, die bei uns Drittmittelprojekte abwickelt, gemeinsam mit, also Forschungsprojekte – quatsch – also Drittmittelprojekte in dem Forschungsbereich. Die Forschungs-GmbH hilft Forschungsprojekte und Aufträge durchzuführen. Professorinnen und Professoren dürfen Nebentätigkeiten ausüben an Hochschulen, müssen aber sehr genau aufpassen in welchem Rahmen, und in welchem gesetzlichen Rahmen, in welchem Umfang usw. das ist durch diese Freiheit von Forschung und Lehre nicht unbedingt immer so einfach erklärbar. Das ist gut geregelt und gut gehandhabt, aber das ist ein wirklich relativ kompliziertes Feld, was aber für uns sehr lohnend ist. Also wenn unsere Professorinnen und Professoren in Nebentätigkeit noch nah an der Praxis sind, sind sie für uns auch besonders wertvoll.
Wir brauchen ja genau das. Und da haben wir diese GmbHs gegründet, die helfen, diese Projekte abzuwickeln und durchzuführen und zu akquirieren und abzurechnen usw. das ist alles quasi – das klingt so negativ, wenn ich sage, dass das alles sauber läuft – aber dass das alles korrekt laufen kann und unsere Professorinnen und Professoren da tätig sein können, die Unternehmen was davon haben, wir was davon haben, aber die Tätigkeit an der Fachhochschule damit nicht beeinträchtigt wird auch im rechtlichen Sinne vor allem.
Dass es sozusagen dadurch gekapselt ist und auch finanziell durch die beschränkte Haftung eben absichert ist.
Genau und was Quersubventionierung angeht usw. das sind einfach Felder, wo man leicht in einen Bereich rutscht, in den man nicht rutschen wollte. Und das haben wir hier alles sehr klug und anwenderfreundlich gelöst.
Und die Leute, die in der GmbH wirken, eher Leute von außen oder eher Leute von innen? Also sind es Leute aus dem Hochschulkontext, die dort dann in dem geänderten Umfeld arbeiten?
Richtig genau. Die ihre Projekte darüber abwickeln. Das ist dann ein Professor bei uns von der Fachhochschule, der hat ein bestimmtes Projekt akquiriert und das wird über die Projekt GmbH abgewickelt. Und dort haben wir Juristen sitzen, die helfen bei der Vertragsgestaltung und andere Personen, die helfen bei den Abrechnungen. Also das ist nochmal ein Bereich, der wirklich ein tolles Serviceangebot für unsere Hochschullehrer ist. Das muss man nämlich auch dazu sagen, es ist ja gar nicht so einfach, gute Leute für Fachhochschulen zu akquirieren. Und wenn wir denen sagen können, wir wollen ja, dass die alle aus der Wirtschaft kommen oder möglichst viele, also dass sie mit Praxiserfahrung an die Fachhochschule kommen. Das ist ja auch nochmal anders als der Rekrutierungsweg an der Universität. Das heißt wir müssen Leute finden, die in der Praxis arbeiten und auf die Idee kommen, an einer Fachhochschule Professorin oder Professor zu werden.
Das ist nicht so logisch, wie wenn ich an einer Universität studiert, dann an einer anderen promoviert, habilitiert und dann gucke ich, wo gibt es offene Professorenstellen. Hier ist es anders. Wir müssen uns die Leute, wir ziehen die nicht selber heran. Sondern wir müssen die von außen holen. Und das ist auch etwas, was die Arbeit an der Fachhochschule Lübeck sehr attraktiv macht. Nämlich, dass man sagt, sie können ihre ganzen Kontakte in die Praxis sehr wohl behalten, da sind wir sogar sehr froh drum und sie müssen auch nicht alle Projekte abgeben. Sondern wenn sie da noch etwas haben, was sie in Nebentätigkeit noch weiter durchführen wollen, haben wir hier die Strukturen, die ihnen das ermöglichen. Und das ist etwas, was ich eine ganz tolle Kombination finde.
Das macht sozusagen attraktiver, weil man nicht so raus ist aus dem Umfeld, was einem ja vielleicht auch ganz gut gefällt, wo man immer mal Lust hat, was zu machen. Man weiß einfach, ich kann hier sowohl jetzt die Lehrtätigkeit übernehmen und da einfach auch mal ganz anders wirken als bisher, aber ich habe trotzdem die Möglichkeit, eine Forschung voranzutreiben und mit dieser Forschung auch wieder direkt in Kontakt zu treten mit meinem bisherigen Umfeld oder eben auch anderen Branchen?
Richtig. Und dabei auch die Lehre aktuell zu halten.
Weil man darüber dann natürlich auch lernt und dann nicht so diese Entkopplung hat, die ja auch häufig kritisiert wird, auch zurecht, dass man nur noch in seinem vor 20 Jahren gelernten Modus arbeitet und dann die neuen Trends gar nicht mehr mit einfließen lässt.
Genau.  Was nicht bedeutet – also das ist schon sehr klar geregelt – es soll nicht bedeuten, dass man dann nur ein bisschen nebenbei lehrt an der Fachhochschule und ansonsten sein schönes Leben. Also dass man die Härten der Wirtschaft gegen das nette Beamtentum austauscht und trotzdem weitermacht wie bisher, also das ist nicht der Fall. Wir haben schon wirklich sehr hohe Lehrverpflichtung von 18 Stunden die Woche. Wir haben Verpflichtungen, zu forschen. Wir haben Verpflichtungen, in der Selbstverwaltung mitzuarbeiten. Aber wir bieten eben auch ein Fenster, wo man Nebentätigkeiten durchführen kann und davon profitieren wir sehr wohl auch selber.
Da ist ja jetzt schone eine ganze Menge Zukunft implementiert wordne in der FH hat man so den Eindruck, zumindest was steht denn noch an? Also was sind denn noch die großen ungelösten Faktoren oder wo sehen Sie denn quasi so die Punkte, wo man jetzt nochmal anpacken muss? Wo es vielleicht noch nicht so läuft, wo Sie Verbesserungspotenzial sehen? Vielleicht jetzt unbedingt nur an der Fachhochschule Lübeck, sondern einfach generell?
Welt retten.
Ich meine hier war jetzt auch schon einiges drin, denke ich, wo manche andere Fachhochschulen auch nochmal reinschauen können und sagen können, vielleicht passt das auch für uns dieser Trend. Aber was sind auch noch so Bereiche, wo Sie Potenzial sehen für die nächsten zehn Jahre? Was sind so die Herausforderungen, die als nächstes an die Tür klopfen?
Fangen wir mal bei der Fachhochschule Lübeck an. Ich möchte gerne, dass wir die Stärken, die wir jetzt ja sehr ausführlich besprochen haben, dass wir die behalten und weiter ausbauen. Also es geht mir jetzt gar nicht darum, da noch etwas neues drauf zu setzen. Das würde ich hierfür gar nicht sinnvoll finden, sondern es muss uns gelingen, die Stärken, die wir jetzt haben, in die nächste Generation zu überführen. Das ist wirklich eine Herausforderung für die nächsten Jahre. Weil die die in den 90er Jahren angefangen haben, das mit aufzubauen, die sind jetzt alle noch da und für die muss man dann irgendwann eine Nachfolge suchen und muss jemanden haben, das kann ich selber jetzt noch gar nicht sagen, wie der Technologie- und Wissenstransferbereich beispielsweise in 5 oder in 10 Jahren aussehen sollte. Aber was ich sagen kann, ist, dass wir jetzt schon uns darum kümmern müssen, dass wir die richtigen Leute finden, die sich dann damit beschäftigen.
Und die diesen Bereich in die Zukunft führen können. Ich möchte also gar nicht unbedingt hier jetzt groß umsteuern, sondern das was wir haben weiter stärken und an die nächste Generation übergeben und dann mit denen gemeinsam neue Schritte und neue Wege ausloten, was immer das dann sein mag in fünf Jahren. Ich finde es nach wie vor richtig und konsequent, dass wir die Bereiche weiter miteinander verzahnen. Wir sind jetzt auch dabei, den Technologie- und Wissenstransferbereich weiter zu internationalisieren. Da geht es also besonders um EU-Förderung. Das ist etwas was Klein- und mittelständischen Unternehmen oftmals schwerfällt, da auch Mittel zu beantragen und in die Projekte einzusteigen, wo wir als Hochschule sehr sehr gut mitarbeiten können, unterstützen können. Das finde ich also genauso konsequent, wie den E-Learning Bereich weiter zu internationalisieren. Also die Verzahnung unserer Schwerpunkte ist ein ganz logischer nächster Schritt, der schon passiert und der weitergehen soll.
Und was mir sehr gut gefallen würde ist, noch weiter in die Welt hinauszutragen, was für eine Perle diese Fachhochschule Lübeck ist. Das ist etwas, wo sehr viel Bescheidenheit herrscht vor Ort und sehr sehr sympathisch. Ich denke, dass es uns aber gut tun würde, noch ein bisschen mehr zu trommeln und zu wirbeln und zu zeigen, wie fantastisch das ist, was dort läuft. Da müssen wir glaube ich noch ein bisschen stärker einsteigen und besonders vor den Hinblick, dass das ja alles so gut läuft, weil wir so unglaublich gute Leute vor Ort haben und wenn wir weiterhin gute Leute akquirieren wollen und die guten Leute auch halten wollen, dann würde es uns meines Erachtens nicht schaden, wenn wir noch ein bisschen deutlicher herausarbeiten und klarmachen, dass wir diese Stärken haben und dass das so eine interessante Fachhochschule ist.
Das ist ja auch eine Frage der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit?
Richtig.
Was macht da die Fachhochschule schon? Was will sie tun?
Wir sind, auch wenn das viele an der Fachhochschule selber nicht unbedingt glauben, aber wir sind in diesem ganzen Bereich sehr sehr schlank aufgestellt. Das heißt wir fahren da meiner Ansicht nach ein relatives Minimalprogramm, einfach weil wir die Personen gar nicht haben. Wir haben also eine neue Internetseite bekommen, das finde ich war absolut notwendig. Das ist ein langer langer schwieriger Prozess üblicherweise an Hochschulen, also das ist absolut nicht Fachhochschule Lübeck spezifisch. Das ist ganz wichtig. Wir haben die ganzen üblichen Themen wie Messen und Anzeigen usw. aber ich denke, hier müssen wir die nächsten Jahre investieren und neu einsteigen und vorangehen. Das ist aber etwas, was an Hochschulen nicht gern gesehen wird, dass man quasi in den Marketingbereich so investiert. Das ist ja, eigentlich sollten die Leute das von selber finden und raus finden. Ich denke aber, das funktioniert so nicht mehr.
Wir müssen ein bisschen klarer auftreten, deutlicher auftreten, peppiger auftreten vielleicht auch, weil das ist eine absolute innovative Hochschule, das kann die ruhig nach außen mehr tragen. Also das fände ich nochmal sehr wichtig.
Wer wäre die Zielgruppe? Geht es hier wirklich nur um Lehrkräfte oder geht es auch um die Studenten selber?
Auch um Studierende. Ich wäre wirklich begeistert, wenn sich bei uns sehr sehr viele Studierende bewerben. Nicht nur aus der Region, das ist ja ganz typisch in Deutschland, dass man immer noch nach der Region die Hochschule auswählt, sondern dass wir wirklich überregional und international studierende anziehen und dadurch auch mehr Auswahl treffen können. Das ist natürlich dann auch wieder aufwendiger, aber ich denke, das würde uns auch nochmal, das würde den deutschen Hochschulen generell sehr gut tun. Das ist denke ich wirklich eine große Herausforderung, wo wir rein investieren sollten. Wir haben an der Fachhochschule Lübeck ein Thema, das habe ich vorhin schon angesprochen, was nicht nur unsere Hochschule und nicht nur deutsche Hochschulen betrifft, sondern generell Hochschulen weltweit und das ist das, wo ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, wofür es diesen Begriff "Third Mission" gibt.
Also dass man neben dem Auftrag Forschung und Lehre noch unglaublich viele weitere Aufträge hat und mein Gefühl ist es, dass man an einer Hochschule relativ schnell dabei ist, neue Projekte und neue Themen zu beginnen. Weil das auch einfach Spaß macht, muss man sagen. Es ist eigentlich immer spannend, es ist immer eine tolle Idee. Es macht natürlich Sinn, ganz ganz intensiv, sich um seine Alumni zu kümmern. Es macht natürlich Sinn, wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, in den ganzen Karriereberatungsbereich weiter einzusteigen und auch den zu internationalisieren. Es ist natürlich wichtig, dass wir Gleichstellung und Diversity vorantreiben. Ein internationaler Campus wäre ganz fantastisch. Ein großes Marketing und eine dreisprachige Beschilderung der Hochschule würde uns gut tun. Wir haben bei uns den Bereich …
Das wäre dann Englisch und Chinesisch?
Richtig ja. Bei uns ja. Woanders vielleicht anders. Entrepeneurship haben wir gemeinsam mit der Universität ein großes Projekt laufen, gut laufen. Gründer Cube heißt das. Also all diese Bereiche, die ich nenne. Jetzt ist in Schleswig-Holstein gerade das Thema Nachhaltigkeit vom Ministerium aufgegriffen worden. Und damit meinen sie wirklich Nachhaltigkeit in allen Bereichen, die man sich nur vorstellen kann, das ist mein Gefühl. Also wir könnten uns den lieben langen Tag mit lauter zusätzlichen Themen und Projekte beschäftigen und neue Abteilungen gründen und bestehende Abteilungen ausweiten und noch in Facebook einsteigen und dies und jenes noch machen und irgendwann sind alle Leute krank. Das ist mein Eindruck. Also was Hochschulen wirklich schlecht können, ich spreche jetzt mal nur für meine, ich glaube aber, dass das übergreifend ist, Projekte dann auch wieder beenden oder einfach mal sein lassen.
Und sich Luft verschaffen wieder für neues. Ich habe das in meinem letzten Job mal nur für Abteilung versucht, dass ich gesagt habe, wir reduzieren jetzt alle um 30%, damit sind wir dann plötzlich auf der sicheren Seite, wenn jemand mal in Urlaub geht oder mal krank wird oder wie auch immer und wir schaffen uns Luft für neues. Lasst uns mal wirklich in jeden einzelnen Bereich rein gucken, was können wir ausmisten? Was machen wir, weil wir es schon immer so gemacht haben oder weil wir es so liebgewonnen haben oder was machen wir vielleicht auch nicht effektiv oder was machen wir hier, was woanders vielleicht auch gemacht wird? Und gucken einfach mal. Und das ist ein ganz schmerzhafter Prozess am Anfang, weil man denkt, man nimmt sich damit seine Wichtigkeit. Das ist aber totaler Quatsch. Man muss es schaffen, auch mal auszumisten, um wieder Platz für neues zu haben.
Und man schärft ja dann seine Prioritäten damit auch.
Richtig. Und das ist was, was ich sehr sehr gerne auch für die Hochschule angehen würde. Das habe ich aber noch nie gemacht, das habe ich bis jetzt mal für eine Abteilung gemacht, das habe ich aber noch nie für eine Hochschule gemacht. Das mache natürlich auch nicht ich, sondern das müssten die Leute dann selber machen. Aber einfach ein Bewusstsein dafür schärfen, es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm, wenn wir auch mal was – also wir sind nicht gescheitert, bloß weil wir mal etwas dann nicht mehr weiterführen. So wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, es werden Kompetenzzentren auch mal geschlossen, wenn sich die Professorenschaft verschiebt und genauso selbstverständlich müsste man dann auch in andere Bereiche gehen, um da wirtschaftlicher zu denken und zu sagen, ja wir haben jetzt die Kapazität und den Raum und den Platz geschaffen, auch mal wieder für was neues.
Das reduziert wahrscheinlich auch so potenzielle Burnout-Problematiken.
Ich würde es hoffen ja. Und ich denke, dass das ganz ganz wichtig ist, immer hinzugucken. Und vor allem wenn was neues kommt, wenn gesagt wird, so jetzt wollen wir aber unbedingt das Thema Gesundheitsmanagement noch aufnehmen in unsere Hochschule für Studierende und für Mitarbeiter, dass man sagt, okay wunderbar, was lassen wir denn dafür? Und da muss man dann ran. Das sind ja auch nicht immer dieselben Personen, die das machen. DAS ist also nicht ganz einfach, aber ich denke, ansonsten fängt man an, sich sehr sehr zu verzetteln und auch dann wächst auch irgendwann die Unzufriedenheit. Man darf aber zu viel, das soll nicht heißen, dass man Projekte abblockt, also das ist überhaupt nicht der Punkt. Wenn jemand kommt und sagt, das will ich unbedingt machen und brenne ich für, ja super. Aber es darf nicht dazu führen, dass man dann nur noch diese Tätigkeiten macht und mit hechelnder Zunge in seinem Alltag umher rennt.
Dann vielleicht zum Schluss doch nochmal allgemein vielleicht für alle Hochschulen nochmal die Frage, was ist sagen wir mal, was sollten die wichtigsten Themenstellungen sein, die sich auch andere Hochschulen oder auch Universitäten auf die Fahnen schreiben sollten? Also wo sehen Sie die großen Herausforderungen gerade, denen die Lehranstalten da ausgesetzt sind, denen sie vielleicht noch zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit schenken?
Ja könnte ich es mir ganz einfach machen und einfach sagen, wir haben alle zu wenig Geld. Da würde mir jetzt keiner widersprechen und das wäre prima und damit könnten wir das ganze beenden. Das fände ich aber zu kurz gegriffen. Ich finde das eine ganz schwierige Frage, weil wir auch eine Vielfalt im deutschen Hochschulsystem haben, die ich sehr begrüßenswert finde, also was weiß ich, dass wir beispielsweise Fachhochschulen und Universitäten haben und außeruniversitäre Forschungseinrichtungen und für all die gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche Zielsetzungen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob sie auf ein Thema hinausgehen, dass man sagt, um Gottes Willen, wir müssen unbedingt am Thema Klimawandel bleiben oder Antibiotikaresistenz.
Nein nein, es ging mir mehr um so, wo wir uns im Prinzip auch schon bewegt haben, also im Sinne von Selbstverständnis und organisatorische Fragen. Im Prinzip, worüber wir ja die ganze Zeit reden ist, wie manage ich eigentlich ein Hochschulsystem? Wie ist mein Selbstverständnis auf im Verhältnis zwischen Studierenden und Lehrkörpern und dann eben auch, wie stellen wir uns auch gegenüber der Außenwelt auf? Wie kooperieren wir mit Unternehmen? Wie ist unser Verhältnis auch zur Gesellschaft? So habe ich das raus gelesen. Wenn man sagt, ja Moocs sind vielleicht nicht erforderlich, aber da haben dann auch noch andere was davon und das erfüllt auch unseren Bildungsauftrag. Das ist ja dann sagen wir mal auch so eine Grundethik, die an der Stelle eine Frage mit auch beantwortet. Also dass man hier auch sagt, wenn wir es uns sozusagen leisten können, auch noch andere teilhaben zu lassen, dann erfüllen wir unseren Auftrag besser.
Wenn wir bessere Methodiken haben, um mit der Wirtschaft zusammenzuarbeiten, dann ist das sowohl für die Lehrer als auch für die Studierenden gut. Das sind ja organisatorische Fragen und ja was sind die nächsten organisatorischen Maßnahmen, die sich anbieten oder denen man begegnen muss, weil sie jetzt gerade ein dringendes Problem darstellen? Vielleicht gibt es ja auch keine, weiß nicht?
Also ich tue mich mit der Frage sehr sehr schwer. Ich möchte auch ungern für alle Hochschulen sprechen. Ich sehe mich nicht in der Lage, vorauszusehen, womit die RWTH Aachen beispielsweise kämpft oder die Fachhochschule Lübeck, finde ich schwierig. Was ich aber schön finde, was Sie eben genannt haben ist tatsächlich dieser Aspekt der Bildung und die Wertschätzung für Bildung und die Wertschätzung für unser vielfältiges System und den Stellenwert, den Bildung insgesamt hat. Das ist etwas, wo ich mich wünschen würde, ich breche es jetzt mal wieder runter im Kleinen, dass wir diesen Wert wirklich sehr sehr deutlich nach außen tragen. Wir sind ja auch zum größten Teil, also zumindest die öffentlichen Hochschulen, sind steuerfinanziert.
Das heißt wir haben einen gesellschaftlichen Auftrag, das ist kein Selbstzweck, weshalb wir existieren, sondern wir haben einen gesellschaftlichen Auftrag. Der ist an unterschiedlichen Hochschulen unterschiedlich, aber es geht immer um das große Thema Bildung und was ich mir sehr wünschen würde ist, wenn wir es schaffen, dass in Deutschland als Gesamtsystem noch stärker zu verstehen. Also ich würde hier sehr gerne über die eigentlichen Hochschulen hinausgehen und sagen, Bildung beginnt ja schon sehr viel früher für die Hochschulen, das Klientel wird ja großgezogen in anderen Institutionen, Krippe, Kindergarten, Grundschule, Schule und dann landen sie irgendwann bei uns oder auch nicht. Und was mir gefallen würde wäre, wenn wir diese einzelnen Bereiche noch stärker zusammen denken. Wenn wir es vielleicht sogar schaffen würden, eine gemeinsame Institution zu gründen als Dachverband oder wie auch immer, die einfach für das Thema Bildung steht und sehr stark einsteht.
Und nicht quasi Universitäten auf der einen Seite, Hochschulen auf der anderen. Unsere Hochschulenrektorenkonferenz, die quasi die Stimme aller Hochschulen, der Fachhochschulen und Universitäten schafft es auch nicht immer, mit einer Stimme zu sprechen, also man wird dann so kleinteilig, jetzt im ganzen Bafögthema sieht es plötzlich so aus als müssten sich Hochschulen und Universitäten und Kindergärten gegeneinander positionieren, wer bekommt das Geld denn jetzt? Das finde ich ist etwas, was eigentlich überhaupt nicht sein darf, sondern wir müssen sagen, wir gehören alle zusammen. Wir brauchen sehr gute Krippen, wir brauchen sehr gute Kindergärten, wir brauchen sehr gute Schulen, damit wir hinterher sehr gute Studierende auch bekommen können. Wobei jetzt Studium nicht der einzige gute Weg ist, das will ich damit nicht sagen. Aber dieser Bildungsgedanke gemeinschaftlich den zu betrachten, was immer das für die einzelne Institution bedeutet, das würde mir gut gefallen.
Es ist jetzt nicht sehr konkret ausformuliert, aber ich hoffe, dass so der Grundgedanke, das Gefühl, das dahinter steht, dass wir das wirklich rüber bringen. Was für eine großartige Sache Bildung ist und sein kann. Und wie wertvoll, auch wenn das bei uns an Hochschulen sozusagen nichts kostet.
Ja Frau Helbig, ich glaube jetzt haben wir es ganz gut zusammengetragen. Ich fand das sehr interessant. Das war mal wirklich so ein …
Riesen Rundumschlag.
Ja genau. Aber ist ja auch nicht so ganz einfach, zu verstehen, wie funktioniert eine Hochschule, was muss man eigentlich überhaupt?
Mir schwirrt der Kopf von den Themen, die wir jetzt hatten.
Aber das sind die Themen, die Sie nun täglich bearbeiten müssen.
Ja genau.
Ja insofern nochmal vielen Dank.
Danke an Sie.
Und vielen dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Das war die 15. Ausgabe, aber nicht die letzte und ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.